so you always start with uh trying to
find
a topic so these are often um
used or the resources that are often
used are ncbi i mean repositories like
pubmed and bio projects and gene
expression omnibus these are all there
and sra these are the repositories where
you will find publicly available data so
you can start with a pubmed and then
look for a search for
some of the topics that that
that
excites you and for example let's say
that if i want to
work on sars so obviously sars and
corona virus
these topics are famous for the last two
or three years in the phantom future
dynamic era so um once you understand
different questions and different uh
reviews that are done on sars maybe you
will find a very interesting topic so um
and they say uh this topic of uh
uh understanding the imbalance host
response to a coronavir infection so uh
is is a one that excites you so what
what do you do so you you start to find
data sets that will that are either
associated with this publication or a
data set that are associated with hosts
response to sars infection so if you
find data sets that are associated with
this publication then you can explore
the data set for possible trend and that
will design your uh
query or design your question or you can
as i mentioned so generally search in
the databases mentioned above like gene
expression omnibus or sra or bioproject
databases for uh host response of human
uh courses response for suscroft
infection
so uh
this
this paper has a data set associated
with that so we can see the accession
number the geo ids so we can get through
the gu id so this data set in the gene
expression omnibus data page will give
you uh some basic information about what
the data is all about and what was what
was the study design and what was
studied and what are the
samples involved and what are the
different replicas of the samples that
we can find
so
and this also gives you access or this
also gives access to
processed data
so we are not going to
perform a detailed analysis of the
process data but the process data is an
excellent place for you to start looking
for the trends that will answer your
questions so uh
when you take the process data and then
quickly perform a principal component
analysis to study the
sample distribution across the
transcriptomics data in this case
then you can if you if you can find such
trends which is uh
which can clearly separate samples that
are
that are of control type and samples
that are given or that are
subjected to treatment from rba and
obviously so this trend gives you a lot
of promise that you can specifically
focus on for example uh responses to you
to rba and responses due to rvc when
compared to the control samples so you
have to do perform such a basic
exploratory analysis on the processed
data that is available on almost all of
the
geo data assets so this could be a back
and forth process some of the data set
might not be conducive
for
for a linear analysis like pca and some
of the dataset could be
large and you you have to go through
this process for a couple of uh more
than one data sets that's what i more
than one data set that's what i like so
um
so uh this trend is promising so when
when we see such a promising trend so we
collect the raw data that is also linked
to uh
to the
sra or shortly disassembling database
from this geo database all of these are
all of these are from the one umbrella
data repository ncpi okay
so we collect the raw data
first queue data and then perform our
own analysis or design our own analysis
process for them
for the raw data so why do we do that uh
we can for example
check uh if difference in a couple of
analysis uh algorithms that we choose
will change the data or maybe we can
take the
raw data and perform our own
normalization or processing or different
processing methods and most of the
processing uh downstream analysis
methods that you are going to employ
will require the raw output from
such a pipeline um of uh which is a
sequence of analysis that you employ
with a fast queue or high throughput
sequencing
so we pre-process the data and then we
map it on to the reference genome for
example and
we quantify the mrna molecules that are
mapped onto different genes so this is a
very short
step-by-step process of transcriptomics
analysis this is just one example of
variety of different analysis that you
can perform on comics data so this will
actually give you uh
uh or this can actually result in a
downstream analysis from which we can
learn what are the diff what are the
genes that are differentially expressed
when you compare two conditions for
example in here treatment through one
rotovirus tray or treatment to the other
data by the strain compared to the
control samples
so uh you can design your own analysis
methods that is different from the one
that is published or you can use an
updated version of the human genome
reference so you you have a variety of
different reasons to perform your own
analysis methods so uh
once you perform these analysis and get
hold of structured data then you can
start exploring the data for the
possible
patterns and well-defined patterns we
already had a hint of the trend that
could be export from the data and then
these pattern exploration or this data
exploration will tell you uh the
necessary transformation or
normalization that you need to perform
so that you can use variety of different
downstream analysis that will
validate your hypothesis so that will
throw right on the question that you are
working with
so yeah
so then you can perform in-depth
analysis on the structured output you
can perform
for example you can identify different
genes that are differentially expressed
and then from the genes you can identify
the pathways that are
enriched or you can identify
which specific
network that is
biological net uh pathways and
uh network network of genes that is
involved in characterizing this response
for example and then we can also study
various different uh
biology
of the sample like if your data involves
tria involves response to a drug
resistance on treatment resistance then
we can also study the basic
behind these development of this
resistance from these analysis for
example
and at last you will have to after
performing the data analysis and after
performing the biological implication
implications you have to uh string all
of these
in a one good story or one good project
that will link
what you have done and how you have done
it and uh what you infer the most from
the variety of different
different analysis that you have
performed for the uh project so uh yeah
this and then once you have completed or
compiled uh the project
report then you can publish that in our
public in our nano mix logic
portal and um
and that will be public to many people
and you can share it with your peers and
then yeah you can also if you create a
poster like this you can also share
those poster in the
in the symposium or in several meetings
that you are going to get so uh
next up
we yeah here are some of the latest uh
or some of the projects that are
developed in our platform and uh which
are part of the research fellowship
program from various different uh
yeah specializations so we have uh for
example in this case
okay this is a poster for project done
in collaboration between
memorial institute for medical research
and this poster is on
malarial parasite plasmogen falciparum
and its antigen and which is a antigen
with a
rotary neck protein binding
so the interactions sorry so this
interaction is extremely critical uh for
this um
for the false param to invade uh into
host human response uh human uh uh
hosts red blood cells so uh
different malaria vaccines are actually
that are known to
prevent such such binding and to prevent
this
interaction and
[Music]
and
these different
candidates or these different vaccines
have variety or variable success or
variable successes at different stages
so this study actually performs a
hypotype
analysis or network analysis of genomic
sequence data
uh from the uh from the
variable infection rates and it compares
uh with the
data that is from the repository uh from
another region so by mapping on to the
genomic variants
that is
that one identified from this hypnotype
study onto the protein structure they
this paper or this poster actually
concludes uh that there are some local
variations and there are some
epitope affecting variations in
geographical locations that are
different for different malaria
parasites and that needs to be taken
into consideration while ah while
developing vaccines
for malaria in a bulk so and also you
can also
publish your results in
in bioarchive preprint then you have a
paper or almost an ear publication ready
output that is available in that
in the public and you can link it to
your orcid id and then you can
also share it with your uh
yeah share it with your peers or have it
use
one of the best way to store your uh
almost ready uh
projects so uh there are other ways to
do this also so uh and you can also
develop your profile and then
this is uh this is from sima dolaner and
who finished her projects and were
rebooted and she was able to work on
leukemia and um
and identify
differentially expressed genes and
protein coding genes that are involved
in
biogenesis and uh
of these leukemia cells and she also
identified several non-coding ironies
and
that are found to be significantly
expressed on this uh this culminated
into a research paper so you can you can
also
uh publish your research uh if you are
if your research fellowship is a very
promising results or if this could be uh
this could set the stage for further
analysis that could result in a very
promising